la ovulación es una parte del ciclo
menstrual en la que el ovario libera un
óvulo maduro o huevo dentro del ovario
hay cientos de miles de folículos cada
folículo es una bola hueca de células
con un óvulo y maduro en el centro
el típico ciclo menstrual de 28 días
comienza el primer día del sangrado
menstrual durante los primeros 7 días
del ciclo algunos folículos comienzan a
crecer al mismo tiempo estos folículos
que están madurando segregan hormonas
estrógenos en el flujo sanguíneo para
preparar las paredes del útero para el
embarazo
alrededor del día 7 todos los folículos
excepto 1 dejan de crecer y comienzan a
degenerarse este folículo dominante
continúa creciendo y alimenta el óvulo
en desarrollo dentro del mismo
alrededor del día 12 el folículo segrega
una gran cantidad de estrógeno en el
flujo sanguíneo cuando el estrógeno
llega al hipotálamo y la glándula
pituitaria del cerebro la parte anterior
o delantera de la glándula pituitaria
libera un gran volumen de hormona
luteinizante en el flujo sanguíneo
alrededor del día 14 la hormona
luteinizante hace que el folículo sufra
un crecimiento acelerado y repentino
justo antes de la ovulación el óvulo se
desprende del interior del folículo el
folículo protuberante libera químicos
haciendo que una de las dos trompas de
falopio se mueva más cerca del folículo
y lo rodee
[Música]
el folículo se hincha hasta que se abre
de golpe expulsando al óvulo y al
líquido del folículo en la cavidad
abdominal
en consecuencia la fibra y minúsculas
proyecciones al final de la trompa de
falopio pasa rápidamente por el lugar de
la ovulación y recoge al óvulo los
cilios microscópicos sobre la superficie
de la fibra transportan al óvulo hacia
la entrada de la trompa de falopio
dentro de las paredes de la trompa de
falopio las contracciones musculares
empujan suavemente al óvulo hacia el
útero después de la ovulación el óvulo
vive entre 12 y 24 horas por lo tanto
para que una mujer quede embarazada el
óvulo debe ser fecundado por un
espermatozoide masculino durante ese
periodo si no es fecundado el óvulo se
disuelve afuera y es eliminado junto con
las paredes del útero durante la
menstruación